if i lose a game the stream ends
like don cena
don't lose provisionally rapid rated
okay
i'll have to stay somewhat focused this
game
if toggy is a bodyguard is that a toggy
guard ah
yes it is
that's a very good point
okay so i'm playing um
somewhat new line for me
because i used to play
knight d2
inside of knight f3
also i think c5 is a mistake because of
bishop b5 check
and now the problem for black is there's
no good way to block
because after takes
uh things will hang for black
oh facecam needs to be bigger
is that better
sorry about that
okay hopefully things look and sound
better now
ah knight ft-7
um yeah i can i can smell trouble for
black first of all there's knight f7
which i think just wins upon
of course i want to look at this move
but
the problem is after
takes
bishop hangs but then this bishop hangs
and then this pawn hangs
so it's a question in which pawn i want
to win
this pawn or this pawn probably f7
a minute i have to be careful too queen
a5 check
this isn't so simple queen 85 knight c3
takes
but then the rookings
if the bishop retreats i check him in
the pawn
that looks good yeah this knight defends
the bishop let's do it
this is a very typical
london tactic
i show this in my london course
which is still on sale
london command will give you the the
lowest price
it's a course i made over four years ago
and it's this is a very typical tactic
because very often in london there's
uh tension between the bishops
and especially when this officials are
defending i love you black can lose
material
i love you too
foreskin
okay so it's actually a triple
fork
but it's also discovery
what do we call this discovery plus fork
is a disco fork
yeah the london course it was like eight
hours
over 50 lessons
like various tactical ideas
okay so this is a line i just was
calculating
and the problem for black now is there's
two threats
i guess this defends against both bishop
h6
blocking my path to h7
but then still queen h5 and then if g6 i
win the bishop
if king moves i mates
king d8 f7
[Music]
oh there's a oh there's not a funny line
so i was calculating bishop h6 king h or
queen h5 king d8907
king c7 then queen d5 oh no my queen
now after takes takes it's almost mates
except knights knight takes d5 is not
legal because the knight would be pinned
but that would be such a cool mate with
a king here the knight controlling these
two squares
this knight controlling b6 and c7
and the bishop filling in
it's hard to make that happen with
the queen here
so maybe i would just castle and then
try and set that up
yeah opponents realizing their uh their
doom
there are cases where like the knight
could be trapped but
i think from this position there's more
cases where the knight will
still be a useful attacking piece
so for this game i'm not playing a
random sub
although maybe this this opponent could
be subbed for all i know
um i just hopped in the 10 minute pool
i'm still trying to break 2600
i'm not sure if like when i play a
provisional player
i might still gain rating but i don't
know if i'll gain
more than like half a point
hopefully we'll find out soon
[Music]
please don't lose
well thanks for saying please
it's a magic word
okay i could take
uh what to do
i think i'll just castle
that was original plan
just unpinning the knights
i'm really hoping black plays this
and
a6 will lead to the most beautiful line
um there's another natural looking move
knight f6
but this
probably just gets mated somehow
[Music]
25
[Music]
okay cd4 i think is very similar to the
a6 line against a6 and against this i
think
queen d5 is working
it's crazy but
queen takes d5 my queen will be hanging
hey
and my knight will be hanging hey
hey future youtube
but if takes
ah
it's mate
it's such a weird mate
and if this is captured it's mates
oh no my queen
it's so beautiful
because two things can be taken by pawns
and the king looks like it has breathing
room but
it's being strangled from all directions
it's cool to have seen this idea like
many moves beforehand
[Music]
because i was just fantasizing earlier
but
sometimes fantasies become reality
yeah so there's a made in one threat
um
i had to double check everything to
ensure like there's no crazy
crazy things for back
like these moves
actually both just run into this
oh no my queen
that's a very feel-good move
i'm trying to offer my opponent an early
christmas present
someone says i think you missed maiden
one
yeah yeah i already know i missed made
them well against
queen c8
but it's not haunting me too much
okay knight c6 prevents mate
knight c6 makes me sad though
my queen wasn't taken
so
i think i'll play queen d6
king b6
oh where's a mate
i could also just take can i take the
pawn
i could take the pawn
that's such a funny move
no i can't take the pawn because the
king has a b8 square
okay i almost hung my queen
that's why you always have to realize
what changes in the position
um
[Music]
yeah black now does have a threat so
let's start with this
and then i'll just take the pawn
and now this has pinned
everything in black's position is kind
of stuck
it's black and zoogsmong
is the bishop stock the rook stuck the
night stock this is has no moves
if here i have queen here
maybe a6
i'm still looking for queen sack ideas
oh bishop d2 okay so the bishop wasn't
trapped
opponent wants to take and win my bishop
so i think i'll play knight d8 it's kind
of a stylish move
idea after bishop c3 i take the knight
and it takes its mate
there's a line bishop c3 bishop c6
bishop b4
but then queen e6
that looks pretty good
hey it's gary what's up gary
if you're just joining i had a funny oh
no my queen moment
but the opponent didn't take it i took
on d5
it's such a cool mate whether he goes
we haven't heard gory bits in a while
yeah shout out to gary
links to his twitch and youtube are in
the chat
uh
hey
eric i got my seventh m norm lol oh
let's go seventh i am norm i don't even
have seven i am norms
okay opponent setting up for the next
game kind of
well congrats to gary
also where's my mate
play this move no that hangs with bishop
and why is this kind of difficult
queen c5 king here
okay
um
this move
maybe just a4
a4 looks good enough
just reinforcing the bishop
hugging the queen
yeah this is very kind of cruel
punishment for black
but the opponent's still trying to
survive
and now i have a5
wow
so knight's pin the queen has to take
it's only legal move
and then i'll win the queen
and now queen c5
idea rook a1
which is kind of hard to stop
i mean there's bishop c1
thank you brad mcclelland looking
forward to getting an oh no my queen
hoodie for christmas
smile smile
yeah you can use a merch command whoa
it's i'm a possum
lifong is too shy to ask but he wants to
ask you out on a chess date this fine
evening ah
i'm collabing with leflong next week
actually
we're gonna uh it's probably gonna be
the final collab of the year
also a good game to my opponent
okay i'm collabing with la fong at 2 30
p.m
central time on december 30th
that's a thursday
so
if this goes on youtube before then
be sure to mark it in your calendar
also hi to youtube